MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 116 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel, and I'm here
with my colleague, Melanie
Warrick.
Melanie, how are
you doing today?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm good.
MARK MANDEL: You're good?
MARK MANDEL: That's good.
MELANIE WARRICK:
I'm in the studio.
MARK MANDEL: You're
in the studio.
You haven't left me today.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
haven't left you yet.
MARK MANDEL: No.
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm
back from New York.
MARK MANDEL: Any day
now, you'll leave me.
It's fine.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Back from New York.
I had a really good time
at the Fat* Conference.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: We talked a lot
about fairness, accountability,
and transparency.
And we'll put a link back
into our show notes--
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
MELANIE WARRICK:
For anybody who's
interested in checking out all
the videos that were captured.
But anyways, we're here to
talk about other things today.
We're going to
actually interview
two of our solution architects,
specifically the Director
of Solution Architect Team, and
one of the solution architects
that's on the team, to
learn about all the things
around Solution Architects.
So yeah, we're talking to
Miles and Grace later on.
But first, we always have
our Cool Things of the Week,
and then we also have
our Question of the Week.
Our Question of the
Week, to tease everybody,
is how do I get a Docker
image into Minikube, Minikube.
MARK MANDEL: Minikube.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
Something like that.
It's a K. Anyways, in
Minikube without uploading it
to an external registry and then
downloading it all over again?
Is there an easy way
to do this locally?
That question, of
course, coming from Mark
because he's working a lot
in the space right now.
Let's start with our
Cool Things of the Week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
There's a bunch of
cool things this week.
Why don't we start with the
fact that Cloud IoT Core is now
generally available.
If you're not familiar
with Cloud IoT Core,
it is our fully-managed
service to help securely
connect and manage your
IoT devices at scale.
That's all the buzzwords.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
And apparently,
this general release
is incorporating a
few new features.
You can now publish data streams
from the IoT Core protocol
bridge to multiple
Cloud Pub/Sub topics,
and you can simplify
deployments.
So, check it out.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And we have a whole bunch of
device partners and application
partners, as well.
So if there are particular
devices or application
platforms that you need to be
able to use, check those out.
We'll have a list
there in the blog post.
MELANIE WARRICK: Another
thing we have for the week
is that JupyterLab is
apparently ready in beta
and accessible for all users.
And JupyterLab is
actually coming out
of the Jupyter Group.
And Jupyter is based originally
off of this notebook that's
become very popular in the data
science space, in particular.
This notebook allows
users to create and share
documents that combine
live code with narrative
text, mathematical
equations, visualizations,
interactive controls,
and other output sources.
It's really a useful tool.
And so they built JupyterLab.
And JupyterLab, in
particular, is something
that they're using as this
interactive development
environment for
working with notebooks.
So it is able to integrate
with text editors, terminals,
data file viewers, and
other custom components,
and allow you to basically do
a more comprehensive workflow.
Check it out.
It's really interesting.
And we're going to
actually have a link where
you can find out
more information
and figure out
how to install it.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
For another one, we announced
that Google Cloud Spanner
can now be used as a
vault storage backend.
If you're not familiar
with HashiCorp Vault,
it's a really cool
open source tool
for basically managing secrets.
It's very popular, of course,
with Google Cloud Platform,
as well as Kubernetes.
This is kind of cool because
Spanner is a great way
to have high availability
across multiple regions
and have that as a back end.
So it enables a few things on
Vault that are kind of neat
in terms of like
transactional support as well,
enterprise grade security--
it basically uses the same
security as Cloud Spanner,
which is amazing--
and it's also supported by
Google, which is also nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: If you
want to get started,
you should download
and install the latest
version of HashiCorp Vault.
MARK MANDEL: 0.9.4,
apparently, at time of reading.
MELANIE WARRICK: Good to know.
And then, the last thing we
want to mention for Cool Things
of the Week-- and this is
something I know, especially,
comes straight from Mark's
heart on the gaming side
of the world--
there's a blog post on how to
handle mutating JSON schemas
and streaming pipeline
with Square Enix.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So, this is an
article written, it
looks like, in conjunction with
Square Enix, the game studio.
They make a lot of
really cool games--
"Final Fantasy," "Deus
Ex," "NieR Automata"--
I could go on for a while.
But they talk about,
basically, how
they ingest a wide
variety of JSON data
across a wide
variety of studios--
because they're made up
of a variety of studios--
and how do they handle different
JSON schemas coming through,
and how to deal
with mutating JSON,
and how to handle it when
you have multiple, basically,
people who are ingesting
data through this pipeline.
It's a really cute
article that's
also written in the style of
first, you have like a hero,
and then you have a
character, and then
they have to defeat a boss, and
the boss is the mutating JSON.
And it's really adorable.
MELANIE WARRICK: And it has a
good diagram of the pipeline,
as well as they have a link
at the bottom for those
who want to check out more
common usage patterns for Cloud
Dataflow.
Great.
OK, Mark.
Well, I think it's
time for us to go talk
with Miles and Grace.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do it.
Today, I am ecstatic
to re-welcome
someone who has been
on our podcast before,
but also somebody new.
We have Miles Ward, Director
of Solutions for Google Cloud,
as well as Grace Mollison,
Cloud Solution Architects,
coming to join us today
to talk all about Solution
Architects and Google Cloud.
How are you both doing?
Miles, how are you doing?
MILES WARD: I'm doing
super, super good.
It is a sunny day and
the clouds are out.
Excellent.
Grace, how are you doing?
I didn't manage to mess
up your name, by the way.
GRACE MOLLISON: Quite.
No, I'm fine.
It's 8:30 over here in London.
So I'm looking forward to
having my hot chocolate
before I go to bed.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Very nice.
Excellent So we really want to
talk to you both about Solution
Architects at Google.
What is that role?
What are you all do?
Before we do that, why
don't you tell us a little
about who you both are.
Miles, why don't you go first.
MILES WARD: Sure.
I'm an electric tuba player
that got suckered into helping
with technology.
And my gig over the last
four years here at Google
has been engaging with our
biggest opportunities, our most
sophisticated
customers, and helping
them figure out how to solve
problems with Google's tech.
I've been doing Public
Cloud for about a decade
and spent a lot
of cycles helping
some pretty high visibility,
high criticality projects
come to market.
I spent a bunch of time working
together with the all-star team
in the Obama for America
reelection group,
so that team built some
pretty incredible technology--
1,800 virtual machines,
200 applications
from scratch in six months
with all volunteers--
a whole bunch of fun
projects worked out of that.
And here at Google, we've
been helping enterprises
and start-ups and
small businesses
figure on how to use
our toys, use our toys.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And yourself, Grace?
GRACE MOLLISON: I've also be
working with the Public Cloud
for about 10 years, as well.
I started off doing consultancy
with EMC at that point.
Then I moved to work with
AWS, where I was a solutions
architect there.
And then I ended up at Google
and I do architecture work,
working with customers and
with our wonderful CE team.
And I also spent a lot of time
teaching the rest of my team
how to speak the
Queen's English.
MARK MANDEL: Good on you.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Something I
can definitely get behind.
MELANIE WARRICK: So is tuba
player something, Miles,
that's required to be an
SA, to be a really good SA?
MILES WARD: We don't
limit to 10 years.
It's not a bad start.
The Cloud, from a
technology standpoint,
is growing and changing
very, very rapidly.
So actually the number one
skill we're looking for
is a long history in
learning new stuff.
The platform is evolving
so quickly that we've
got to be able to keep pace.
I mean, none of us
were thinking at all
about machine learning
four years ago.
And now, half of the team
is working in machine
learning tech and making
sure that customers
are able to capture
opportunity there.
So it's a pretty fun gig.
MELANIE WARRICK: Cool.
The question actually was, is
the tuba player part something
that's a required part?
[LAUGHTER]
MILES WARD: [INAUDIBLE].
MELANIE WARRICK: Sure.
But that's a more
practical answer to,
you know, what is
involved in being in SA.
Yes.
MILES WARD: We do not
limit our definition
of weird to including only tuba.
But we do require weird.
So that kind of
structure is really
important in our kind of
evaluation of incoming folks.
We've got a truly
unusual motley crew.
When we go out as a group,
it's a funny looking scene.
So you've got
people from the guy
who deployed a
third of the servers
behind "World of Warcraft."
And Dan has code that's
running in the arm of the Mars
Curiosity Rover.
And we've got folks
that rendered the movies
that everybody
watched and folks that
have helped the banks process
trillions of transactions.
MELANIE WARRICK: Wow.
MILES WARD: It's a
funky group of folks.
GRACE MOLLISON: And
you've also forgot, Miles,
about John, whose birthday
is every single day.
Not many teams have that.
MILES WARD: That's right.
We have a person who has
a birthday every day.
And it really makes
sure that we're
in a constantly
celebratory mood.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
OK.
So apart from being interesting
and strange, at a high level,
what is a solution architect?
GRACE MOLLISON: So,
I'm happy to take that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So I think, Grace,
you should take this
because Miles is not
making any sense.
GRACE MOLLISON: We're
a scaling function.
I mean, basically, I spend
every day of my working week
scaling myself out of a job.
So what that really
means is the fact
that I will work with customers
on net new problems, things
that our documentation
may not quite have clear,
so people can see the logical
flow, particularly when you're
blending a number of products.
And I document that.
We get it published.
And I move on to
the next thing or I
help people to
actually understand,
if the documentation isn't
as clear as it should be,
how they should be
interpreting that.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So if people--
I know I've seen solutions
that have been posted on
like the
cloud.google.com website.
Is that your team, Miles?
Is that what you do?
MILES WARD: Yeah.
100% of the material that's at
cloud.google.com/solutions is
stuff someone from
our team built.
And a bunch of technical
documentation around
the business comes from
or is inspired by a lot
of the pathbreaking work that
we do together with customers.
And that's exactly the model.
Grace is right.
She sort of maybe
under-asserts the degree
to which a lot of this
comes from direct engagement
with customers.
Like Grace is working with
some of our biggest, hardest
opportunities.
And when they get
to a place where
they're scratching their heads
and we're scratching our heads,
we sort of dive in together
to find the answer.
Right?
Whether that's,
there's currently
no floating IP addresses
available as a part
of GCE networking.
So how do you do a software
application that depends
on floating IP addresses?
We do the research.
And we dive in with customers
and do a bunch of experiments.
And the result is
a white paper that
says, here are the
four different ways you
can work around that problem,
that we've seen actually work.
And that kind of
gap-filling and enablement,
you can sort of fake
it and just sort of,
ah, this is probably
how that would work.
But when you do it
together with customers,
it's real and tested and
tested by somebody who really
needs the answer to work.
So it helps us make sure
that the guidance we give
is something that's valuable.
MELANIE WARRICK: You've talked
to a couple of the examples,
but can you guys talk
a little bit more
about the kind of customers,
and who the customers are that
you're working with?
MILES WARD: Sure.
I can provide a couple
of fun examples.
We spent a lot of
cycles with one
of the biggest banks
in the world, HSBC,
in Grace's backyard.
We've been working
through helping
them apply machine learning
and our data platform--
so tools like Dataflow
and Dataprep--
to be able to digest
the bank's data
and perform better
projections, better analysis.
So one example that would be
easy is like fraud detection.
There's however many
millions of dollars a day
of fraudulent charges that
come through that bank.
And I have to do the
guess and go, yeah,
I bet you every other bank
has that problem, too.
So we work together
with this specific bank
to help them build a
fraud detection model,
a machine learning model, on
top of a Cloud Machine Learning
Engine using TensorFlow.
And the output of that
is higher performance
than the current
systems that they have.
So they're implementing
it into production.
And we're going through and
doing the work to figure out,
can we turn this into
a pattern, a solution
that other companies
would implement?
Can we make that
pattern easy enough
that our product teams
start to go, hey, maybe
that should be a product.
It's all part of this
life cycle of discovering
value for customers and
helping them get pieces built.
Like another easy
example, you know,
there was a pretty
big emergency project
with the folks at Evernote.
They wanted to be able to
move all of their systems
over to Google Cloud
in less than 90 days.
Right?
So this is three petabytes
of customer data, hundreds
of independent systems.
And we have a
Professional Services Team
that works really
hard to enable and do
the grunt work of
picking these pieces up.
But there were specific
implementation questions.
How do I get a shard in MySQL
to replicate over the wire?
How do I make it so
that we're able to tune
for improved performance using
Google Super Fast Solid State
Disk?
Those kinds of
questions, when there's
a blocker, when
there's something
we don't know how to do.
Folks from my team-- so
that one was, Brad came in,
Brad [? Svee ?] came in and
asked a bunch of questions
and was able to get down to a
best practices implementation
for their MySQL
system that now we're
replaying to other customers.
So that's the model, is
find these big customers,
help them unpack, and
then teach the rest.
MELANIE WARRICK: And how long
do these types of engagements
last?
MILES WARD: So it's
all over the map.
We have a lot of conversations
where customers are really
just looking for that
first piece of guidance,
right, where maybe a little
better version of Google
when we Google that
for you, right?
Well, you know, maybe we
couldn't find the doc before,
but here's where it is.
Or you know, this is generally
this kind of best practice
that you want.
Some customers have hundreds
of problems, thousands,
and they can keep us busy.
And they continue
to push platform.
So we have some places
where people have
been involved for a long time.
But generally, we're
looking at anywhere
from a superdense phone call to
a couple hours on a white board
to a week of kind of
a proof of concept
or a first implementation.
MARK MANDEL: So we've had
some previous podcast episodes
on talking to people
like, for example,
CEs, Customer Engineers,
sort of account management
side of things.
How do you all differ
from those sort of roles?
I'll pass this over to Grace.
Grace hasn't said
anything in a while.
GRACE MOLLISON:
We don't actually
own any accounts, as such.
They tend to be owned by
the customer engineers
and the account managers.
And essentially, the
customer gatekeeper us.
They request our assistance,
which is how it works.
And we also work
alongside PSO, as well.
So we kind of have
their backs, if you
like, to a certain extent,
is the way I like to see it.
So, as an example--
MARK MANDEL: And what's PSO?
GRACE MOLLISON: Sorry.
As an example, the other day you
mentioned one of the solutions
that I wrote, the JCP Policies.
MARK MANDEL: Yup.
GRACE MOLLISON: One of the CEs
of a large American company
saw that, passed it to their
customer, and then the customer
says, it'd be really good if
we could talk to the people who
worked on that.
So they got myself and the
project manager who helped
me work on some of that work.
And we were on a call
with them yesterday
discussing how they should
approach things, and just
talk them through how
to use those papers.
So that's great.
I often don't get a chance,
once it's been published,
to actually then
talk to people who
are right at the
beginning of even looking
at the documentation.
So that was really
a great experience.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
How do people actually
reach out to you?
GRACE MOLLISON:
So as I said, that
was an example where the
CE found the blog post
and then sent it to the
customer and the customer
said it'd be great if
we could talk to you.
It tends to be, for me
personally, in the UK,
tends to be people reaching out
to me, either by our Project
Managers, particularly
the area I focus on
with security and IM.
In Europe and the
time zones, I tend
to be kind of a first call,
working alongside some of us
specialist CEs.
So we have some CEs who
focus on particular areas.
So we've got some security
focused CEs, as well,
and I work alongside those.
So there's different avenues
to get through to us.
MELANIE WARRICK: OK.
And are there certain
types of projects
that you get asked to
do that you would say
are not a good fit for the
solution architecture role?
MILES WARD: We're no good
at making sandwiches.
You have to say pseudo first
and then all the sudden we
really like making sandwiches.
What we don't want to do is
something we've already done.
Like, that's the
core is we're trying
to be at the front edge of
identifying how customers can
use our platform in new ways.
Grace can go and engage
with that customer who's
thinking through how to apply
policies to their business,
but she's going
to bring CEs with
and they're going to
take a bunch of notes.
And hopefully, the next time
the next customer comes,
they won't have to
bring Grace along.
The CE can handle it.
That's where Grace was
talking about with the scaling
function.
Right?
So, it's not that there
is any individual thing
we don't want to do.
We just don't want
to do it 10 times.
MARK MANDEL: So to
flip that around,
it's worth pointing
out, I guess,
if you go to the /solutions
page on cloud.google.com,
these are not solutions that
were written in isolation.
These were written for customers
to be implemented like,
rubber meets the
road type stuff.
GRACE MOLLISON: Yeah.
MILES WARD: Yeah, exactly.
Like there are so many
production customers
that sit on top of
those patterns that
are following our guidance.
That's the way the role
is supposed to work.
MARK MANDEL: Do you
normally engage with say,
a certain size of customer?
Or is it a broad range, or
a variety of industries?
How does that sort of pan out?
GRACE MOLLISON: I'll
take [INAUDIBLE]
because I happen to work a lot
on the on board and security
side.
And the complexities
you see when
you work with large
strategic customers,
I just tend to work with a
lot larger, a lot more gnarly
enterprisey types.
We've got guidance for sort
of start-ups and greenfields.
But because they're
start-ups and greenfields,
they haven't got the existing
infra, all the issues there,
and everything that you need
to think about how you bring
yourself to the Cloud
without basically
breaking your business.
MILES WARD: The cool
thing with our team
is there's a lot of diversity
in the background and skills.
Cloud Platform's almost
60-something products
at this point.
Plus, you have to sort of
know about all the hardware
and software that there's
ever been on the planet.
So it's impossible
to have coverage.
So like if Grace spends a
bunch of cycles on identity
and security and kind
of enterprise setups,
we have folks that have a
bunch of gaming background
or a bunch of media
background or have
spent a whole bunch of
cycles with retail companies.
Right?
So those types of groups
have different problems.
And we work to resolve
issues at any size.
So the threshold for us is
not looking at like, you know,
who's the very biggest
customer possible,
but which is a customer that
is ready to work together
with us so that we can
learn as much as possible.
Sometimes those are little
tiny companies that are out
in the middle of breaking path.
So, it's all over the map.
MELANIE WARRICK: Miles, with
such a wide range of skills,
how did you find the people
that are on your team?
How did you build this team?
MILES WARD: We're about 78%
referrals at this point.
So there's a phrase,
dorks can smell their own.
So there's a lot of us that
are old friends and that
have been working on these
kinds of problems for a while.
And we take the interviewing
and recruiting process really
seriously.
When this group gets
together, it's just
a bunch of buddies on a couch.
It's a super fun way to
connect and hang out.
And, you know, a
lot of peers who
have really seen high-scale
stuff and high-stakes stuff.
So we're getting
better and better
every day at finding folks
that have the right attitude
and have the right
history of learning.
Even though they may be
from a new set of skills
that it's helping
us cover new areas,
that expansion is
happening all the time.
MARK MANDEL: And are you hiring?
MILES WARD: Yeah, we're
absolutely hiring.
We've got a whole
bunch of spots.
EMEA, Japan, it's a global team.
Because here in the
US, right, if you're
in Mountain View doing
a startup and you
want to talk to an
engineer at Google,
you have a lot of
different options.
And for a single
product, often cases
you can get access
to, over time,
if you're doing
interesting stuff
and pushing the boundaries,
you can get access
to engineers that are working
on the actual products.
In Singapore, you know, we have
folks in Tel Aviv and Korea
and Japan, and you
know, Stockholm now,
and in each of those
places, it's harder
to get access to an engineer.
So a solutions architect also
serve as this technical point
of escalation inside
of the sales process
so that engineers in
our remote territories
have somebody that's at
their level to talk with.
A lot of that ends up
being us supporting
the product, management, and
product development exercise.
MELANIE WARRICK: How would I
know I'm a potential solution
architect?
MILES WARD: We hire on
a Google system that--
they have a whole bunch of
internal labels for the stuff--
but the same kinds
of operations people
that get hired for
their Google SRE role
tend to be a good fit for us.
More of the
questions about Cloud
have to do with how I
make this thing work
and keep it working
than how do I develop
a new application on top.
We have great teams
and developer relations
and others that are helping
our developer friends.
This team tends to spend
more time in operations land.
It also tends to
look for people who
have a background in
hands-on operations
of either large-scaled,
on-premise infrastructure-- so
like, we have an
engineer who used
to run operations for Concur.
And that's all
data center-based,
but it's the same
kinds of problems
they're trying to solve,
as our Cloud customers.
So there's a lot
of customer empathy
that's possible as
a result of that.
So another dimension
in that is Google Cloud
is something that you
boss around with code.
And it's not the
environment where,
you know, if somebody is just
exceptionally good at pointing
and clicking inside
of System Center
or vCenter or
something like that,
that they're going
to be the right fit.
Our customers are asking
us to help them automate,
to help them
instrument, to help them
turn into a dynamic
environment what has
been static and hard to manage.
So we do have a coding bar.
We need people to be able
to help not just explain
solutions, but develop them.
MARK MANDEL: So this should
segue nicely, hopefully.
So I'm curious, I mean, you both
work with a lot of customers.
I'll direct it to you, Grace.
Are you seeing any
particular trends
in terms of the help that
customers are needing,
or the sort of things
that they're doing?
GRACE MOLLISON: Yeah.
So as I said,
that's how I've been
able to produce some
of the work I've done.
I actually work very
closely with customers.
And you start seeing a pattern.
Once you start seeing
those patterns,
you can actually
then convert them
into guides and documents
and tutorials and reference
architectures.
So as an example,
every customer wants
to understand how
they can actually
map their job, their
functional roles, to IM roles.
That's something that
you just need to learn
how to do at the beginning.
So you know, I
just say to people,
step away from the keyboard.
Think about your planning.
Map those role to your IM roles.
And then you can
start implementing it.
Folks also want
to understand how
to automate things, as well.
So that's a very common
question is like,
are they hybrid multi-Cloud?
Do they want to use OSS
solution like Terraform?
Or do they, if
they're all into GCP,
then maybe they have
used Deployment Manager.
So it helps them make
those sorts of decisions,
you know, and looking at the
skill sets they've got already
and just bringing them
on the journey, really.
MELANIE WARRICK: Grace,
what do you enjoy
most about the work you do?
GRACE MOLLISON: I love the
fact that every week I've
learned something new.
I also love the fact that I'm
asked to work with customers.
You know, I have a lot
of respect for our CEs,
particularly, because
they've got a hard job.
And I love working with them.
They are very collaborative.
And you know, I get up every
day really enthused about work.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
know when we both met
before this, I had
asked you, would there
be anything else you would do
other than being a solution
architect.
GRACE MOLLISON: And
I said then, it's
really, really hard to think
of another role that fits me,
personally, and the
stuff that I like to do.
And I think if I
was put on the spot,
maybe I'd look at doing
something into DevRel,
or maybe working in the PM Org.
I mean, they're the two
roles that would fit.
Because I used to do
a CE type role at AWS,
so I know how hard that is.
I've done that.
And it's like evolving.
And at the moment, I
really enjoy this job.
And I can't see
anything that rivals it.
MELANIE WARRICK: You like
everything but Miles, right?
GRACE MOLLISON: Oh, no.
He's terrible.
MILES WARD: There's
this phrase that there
are kind of two kinds
of people in the world,
folks that are entropy
creators, and folks
that are entropy destroyers.
I think you can sort of
make a quick guess as
to which side of that dividing
line Grace and I each land on.
MARK MANDEL: I know you've
published a lot of solutions,
and maybe you can't
necessarily name names,
but what's been the most
interesting solution
that you've had to
provide for a customer?
Grace, we were just
talking to you.
Why don't you go ahead?
GRACE MOLLISON: So,
ironically enough, it's
pretty much in the first
six months that I joined.
I was helping work
with the IM team,
regarding helping
them get it to GA.
We had no real knowledge
at that moment.
How was this going to work?
How would customers go
to interface with it?
So that was a lot of talking
to a lot of big customers
who were able to
give us some input.
So people like
Spotify, for example,
provided a lot of
the input there.
And then it evolved.
So the latest set of
docs, I would say,
were the ones I actually enjoyed
the most because it took some
of the early work and
then it was blending it
with lots of different things.
So I looked at billing
and I looked at networking
and I looked at, you know,
the Cloud Resource Manager.
And I had all of
these bits and I've
got to actually figure
out a logical path
to make it clear and
easy for our customers.
You know, so it was
at the beginning
and the most recent stuff
were the two things I really
enjoyed working on, I think.
MELANIE WARRICK: So, I've
done consulting in my past.
And I know one of the biggest
challenges we were always
up against was scope
creep, and trying to keep,
especially customers, within
the bounds of expectations
and realities of time.
I assume that's one
of your challenges
that you're up against,
in terms of this role.
How do you usually
work with that?
MILES WARD: I'll say that
because the definition
of the team is relatively clear,
that when a customer is blocked
either at the beginning--
I don't think this is
possible on Cloud--
or at the end-- hey, you
people said this was possible
on Cloud--
when they get
blocked and we don't
know how to solve
that problem, that's
exactly when solutions
architects get involved.
And similarly, when
they are unblocked
and they appear to
be able to continue
to move without our
support and assistance,
that's when we go away.
So far, the scope
creep has not been
from the individual projects.
Like generally, people ask
for relatively specific things
because that's the current
long pole in the tent
that they need resolved.
But there's certainly a
very small number of us
and a very large
number of customers.
And so I think the actual
creep is more about,
can we put you at every
customer everywhere?
And that's relatively
complicated
because there's hundreds
of thousands of them
and there's dozens of us.
So the creep is, the
creep is internal.
MELANIE WARRICK: That sounds
like a constant juggling
of prioritizing.
And what are some
other challenges
that you are working
with in terms
of managing this team, Miles?
MILES WARD: My big
job is an easy one.
It's helping our folks continue
to learn the new hard bits.
It's really easy to--
and everybody does this--
you find a place where
you have expertise.
You get relied on for
that expertise by others.
But the world of technology
changes so rapidly
that any amount of real
experience and depth in a given
area has value for
about a decade.
So we have some of
our folks on our team
that have been here
for half that long.
So all of a sudden,
you're going, well,
you're halfway to
having the experience
that you had at the
beginning be not worthwhile.
Maybe you should
learn some new stuff.
So there's a whole
bunch of training
and, you know, some
of that is autodidact.
People dive into
whole new pieces.
Some of it is stuff that
we help people through.
In a lot of cases, following
the solutions architect model,
that's training
that we go build.
That's the best we
know how to learn.
So we didn't have GCP 101,
like the most basic onboarding
training materials to teach
people how this stuff worked.
And Grace had just
started so she wrote it.
And now we have a
training class, right?
Like that was her
way of figuring out
how to run all this stuff.
And that's why we like her.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, and
then off of the learning
point, Grace, what
are some things
that you're excited to
learn about in the future,
in the near future?
GRACE MOLLISON: So I'm
actually pivoting now
to spend more time with the
data loss prevention, the API.
And I'm working very
closely with the PM there.
So I'm really enjoying that
because it's a really fun
product and it's so underrated.
It's just very, very powerful.
And obviously with all the
things regarding PII and making
sure that you can stop sensitive
data getting out early,
it's just a key tool.
That's fine.
And I'm also going to be doing
some work with the stack driver
team, as well.
So it's still in the same area,
but there's just new things
all the time.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So we're running
out of time here.
But before we wrap up, is there
anything that either of you
want to plug or mention or talk
about before we finish things
up here?
Miles?
MILES WARD: We're in the
middle of building some new--
and I'm pretty excited
about-- some new things
to do at our big events, NEXT
and the Global Summit Series.
Those are great
opportunities to connect
with solutions architects.
SAs are always there.
And it's a great way to get
maybe the 15 minute version
of an engagement,
where we can get
on our big whiteboard that's got
all of the architecture icons
and systems and you can
come and hang out with us
and we'll help figure out how
to solve the problem that you've
got.
And so one of the
things that we're
working really
hard on now is kind
of an interactive environment
for that kind of solutioning,
a little bit of a game.
So there will be
more about that as it
gets out and launched and done.
We're still fighting
over the name.
But generally, I think the
events series this year
is going to be a lot of fun.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Grace?
GRACE MOLLISON: We're
hiring, basically.
I'd like to personally see
more females join the Solutions
Architect Team.
But to be honest, it
was the same problem
at my previous role.
It's a fun job.
And you know, you
should give it a chance.
That would be my plea.
Because, you know,
I really enjoy it.
And I'm sure others would, too.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, great.
Thank you, again.
It really was great to
talk to both of you.
Grace, thanks for
hanging in there so late
for us to get you on the call.
GRACE MOLLISON: That's OK.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Yeah.
Thank you to you both.
And I really appreciate
you both taking the time.
GRACE MOLLISON: OK.
Thank you.
MILES WARD: Awesome.
Thanks a bunch.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thanks
again, Miles and Grace,
for coming on the podcast.
That was wonderful to hear about
what solution architects do,
fun stuff you guys
actually do on the side,
and yeah, I'm really glad you
guys were able to join us.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It was a really great episode.
Super happy to hear,
again, from people
who help support our
customers, and how
they can interact with
them if you are a customer.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And to stress what
they were saying in the
podcast, they are hiring.
So you should reach out.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK:
All right, Mark.
Let me ask you the
Question of the Week.
How do I get it a Docker
image into Minikube
without uploading it
to an external registry
and then downloading
it all over again?
Is there an easier way
to do this locally?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So this is near and dear to
my heart, being Kubernetes.
So Minikube is a
really nice tool
for running a Kubernetes
cluster locally.
So usually, what
it does is it'll
run a small virtual machine
that has Kubernetes installed
as a single node installation.
And that's really nice.
The interesting thing
is when you're like,
oh, I built my image locally.
How do I get it into the VM
so that Kubernetes cluster
can see it?
There's a couple of
interesting ways you can do it,
one of which is you can
actually build inside Minikube.
There's ways of doing that.
You can actually mount
your code inside the VM.
That's good.
That works.
But it means you
might necessarily
be double building stuff.
There's other options
where I've seen people
who have installed their own
Docker registry inside Minikube
so that they can push to that
and then sort of pull down
locally from there.
But there's an even easier
way, which I really like,
which works if you're
running a Linux
terminal of any kind,
which is you can actually
pipe the Docker image into
Minikube, which is really cool.
So if you use
Minikube-- and I'll put
a link to the exact command--
but if you've used Minikube,
if you say Minikube
Docker environment,
it will set the
Docker environments
up so that Docker knows,
oh, I'm not running locally.
I'm going to push
all my stuff there.
And there are two commands,
Docker Save and Docker Load.
So Docker Save will take a
image and put it into a file
or put it into a
like output stream.
And Docker Load can take a
file and import it or take it
from the input stream.
So we basically just pipe it.
So you do a Docker Save
with the image you want,
pipe it into any [? value ?]
of the Docker environment.
And then Docker Load and
then it pushes it right in.
You don't need to
local registry.
You can build locally.
Actually, it's really nice.
I like it a lot.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Well, thanks for that, Mark.
And one other question.
Do we have a new sound going on?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Starting last week.
Thanks to our
wonderful editors who
put together our wonderful
new intro and outro music.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Apparently, we've
had a few folks
who've noticed it.
So thanks for giving us a
shout out and letting us
know that you've
been hearing it.
And then last but
not least, I'm going
to mention if you
want to contact us,
you can email us at
hello@gcppodcast.com.
You can reach to us on
Twitter at GCP Podcast.
You can also reach out to us
on Google+ at +GCP Podcast,
at Reddit, which is also
GCP Podcast, and on Slack.
You can just request an invite
to the Google Cloud Slack
community and join
hashtag podcast channel.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
Mark, going anywhere
in the next few weeks?
Got any events?
MARK MANDEL: It's
all about GCP, still.
MELANIE WARRICK: Which
is coming up, when?
MARK MANDEL: Which is coming
up, it's the 19 of March,
off the top of my head.
I'm pretty sure that's right.
MELANIE WARRICK: Fantastic.
MARK MANDEL: We're going to
have a full day Google Developer
Day with a bunch of
different people speaking.
There's booth sessions.
We're having Meet the
Experts at the booth.
That'll be fun.
We're sponsoring some parties.
I'll talk about those
probably next week.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
MARK MANDEL: All
that good stuff.
So we'll definitely be around.
Reach out, come say hi.
I'd love to meet
you if you're there.
MELANIE WARRICK: No mentions
for me for this week.
MARK MANDEL: No.
MELANIE WARRICK: Or the
next couple of weeks.
Not right now.
MARK MANDEL: That's fair enough.
MELANIE WARRICK:
More to come later.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
Melanie, thank
you very much for joining me yet
again on the podcast this week.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: And thank
you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.